[Music]
that's been in La smoking and basically
trapped his 2022 black Mercedes wedged
in tight between two cars when the other
drivers don't show up what happens next
is a skilled almost minute and a half
operation
oh he bumped that blue car then tries a
few more times and another tap he made
contact at least one more time that we
saw the whole thing totally gives us
Austin Powers vibes
all right
[Music]
luckily there was no damage and gotta
say glad Ben's son Samuel wasn't driving
remember when he got behind the wheel of
a Lambo last June and it rolled
backwards into that BMW so actually
celebrated his 11th birthday yesterday
and this weekend Keke Palmer and
boyfriend Darius Jackson welcomed their
baby boy to the world his name leodus
Andrelton Jackson Kiki said Leo was born
during Black History Month with a name
to match
[Music]
yeah
foreign